weiter geht's mit den hässlichsten
Städten Deutschlands und wir haben nach
meiner Heimatstadt als nächstes
Salzgitter salzgitter ist eine Großstadt
in Niedersachsen die eigentlich gar
keine richtige Stadt ist sie hat nämlich
nichts davon was andere Städte ausmacht
es gibt keinen Stadtzentrum der Ort
besteht aus sieben Ortsteilen die
wiederum in Stadtteile aufgegliedert
wurden also ich muss sagen ich war noch
nie in Salzgitter aber Salzgitter kennt
man ja und wenn die da nicht mal einen
Stadtkern haben ist das schon ziemlich
doof also Salzgitter hat mehr mit einem
Landkreis gemeint als mit einer
richtigen Stadt dafür sind die Orte
zwischen Braunschweig und dem Harz
durchaus schön gelegen und die Mieten
die in allen Ortsteilen noch recht
günstig sind Laden eigentlich dazu ein
sofort hierhin zu ziehen stellt euch mal
von eurer Stadt wohnen 70.000 Menschen
es gibt keine Einkaufsstraße oder so